noticias npr esto es considerando todo
soy robert siegel y yo soy michael
norris muchos estudiantes con problemas
en matemáticas han encontrado apoyo en
la voz de este hombre
salman khan empezó haciendo vídeos para
ayudar a su prima pero se volvieron tan
populares que renunció a su empleo en
finanzas para dedicarse a ellos tiempo
completo ahora que han academia en línea
atrae a muchos maestros y alumnos les
presentamos el reportaje del área
bronson sobre los primeros intentos de
llevar al salón de clases el enfoque de
khan es impactante tres estudiantes
juerguistas del norte de california
emplea en el tiempo de escuela para
jugar un juego de computadora como se
llama reto de trigonometría a ver un
medio como 2 x muy bien los niños de
quinto grado michael ryan lucas
minerista mary han profundizado bastante
en el reto de trigonometría de khan
academy están devorando los problemas de
matemáticas como si fueran doritos
la escuela es parte de un programa
piloto de la primaria santa rita en los
altos california están haciendo de khan
academy una parte integral del currículo
de matemáticas
la maestra khamis order son dice que con
media hora al día khan academy
introducía estos chicos en el mundo de
su propio ritmo todos están en etapas
diferentes
algunos están trabajando cálculo y
matemáticas de nivel medio algunos
trabajan la multiplicación de decimales
y eso está bien está bien porque los
alumnos que necesitan ayuda pueden
buscar el vídeo apropiado y escuchar la
explicación de khan academy de conceptos
como variación directa e inversa
salamanca no está en la pantalla del
vídeo y va guiando a los estudiantes con
su enfoque personal paciente y amable
emisor de son dice que los niños se
sienten cómodos buscando la ayuda de
camps es algo que se hace en privado no
tienes que levantar la mano frente a
toda la clase y decir no entendí esto te
puedes ir sin que lo hayas entendido y
nadie tiene
y no hay nada ostentoso en los vídeos en
los ejercicios pero de alguna manera kan
ha alcanzado un punto óptimo que hace de
esto la parte más popular del día
entonces esto al cuadrado te a 36 y esto
al cuadrado te da 9 camby tarde son dice
que durante el tiempo dedicado acá en su
clase parece más un despacho atareado de
ingeniería que un salón de clases
tradicional los niños colaboran los
maestros orientan y no tienen que dar
una clase algunos niños como hannah al
bridge trabajan por su cuenta siguiendo
los ejercicios en línea mientras hacen
cálculos en una pizarra o con papel y
lápiz 90 menos 7 entonces eso sería 83
es como un maestro en línea puede
ayudarte en cualquier lugar puede ser
tan rápido como quieras y no tenemos que
esperar en todo lo que hago necesito
ayuda en la clase de kelly robert y los
chicos anotan su nombre en el pizarrón
alguien ayuda en un concepto otros
ofrecen enseñar algo que ya dominan la
fecha y dice que cambia ayuda a lidiar
con las clases de gran tamaño problema
que incluso este distrito acomodado
enfrenta definitivamente can me ha
ayudado a incidir en todos los
estudiantes así que cuando tienes a
tantos niños terminas enseñando a la
mitad
icann me ha permitido incidir en los más
y en los menos aventajados sería mucho
más que un libro de texto
khan academy ofrece también una especie
de función de respaldo mientras los
chicos hacen ejercicios de manera
independiente rafferty checa su
computadora para ver sus progresos con
esto puedo observar a todos los chicos y
puedo ver quién está teniendo problemas
quién o quiénes han aprobado cuánto les
tomo aprobar me da mucha más información
información que ella puede utilizar para
ver quién necesita más ayuda la
directora de la primaria santa rita
sandra mccord afirma que para ella khan
academy tiene algunas ventajas grandes
sobre otros materiales de matemáticas
uno que es gratuito y fue creado por
personas que en verdad aman las
matemáticas y la calidad es magnífica
después del programa piloto de este año
las escuelas de los altos empezarán a
usar cada académico en todo el distrito
para quinto y sexto grados
khan academy espera ver cómo funciona en
mayor variedad de escuelas y el próximo
año se extenderá
por lo menos diez nuevas escuelas las
clases de matemáticas nunca volverán a
ser lo mismo
branson noticias